AKINDELE AKINROPO: Hello.
My name is Akindele O. Akinropo.
I'm an urban planner studying
sustainable development
in Malaysia.
The study of this
course in this video
compares shopping at two malls.
The first one is
Jusco mall located
in the heart of
Bukit Indah in Johor,
and the other is
Alamanda in Putrajaya,
the administrative
headquarters of Malaysia.
In this video, I want
to share with you
my research on the sustainable
dimensions of shopping malls.
Sustainable development
means different things
to different people.
However, it generally refers to
using environmental resources
in a way that allows other
generations to continue
to use and preserve it.
Shopping in malls
can be sustainable
under certain conditions.
For instance, the processes
of siting, building,
and using malls need to
be properly organized
within the urban system
to promote city livability
and environmental performance.
Mall sustainability
will be guaranteed
when site and operation
discourage carbon emissions,
encourage socialization, and
promote continuous wealth
generation.
This discussion naturally brings
some questions to one's mind.
For instance, are malls
actually important to city
sustainability?
If so, in what specific ways?
What kinds of malls are good
and what other factors make
shopping malls sustainable?
This video will explore the
following empirically observed
points.
Sustainable malls
can and should be
a part of sustainable city
development in the developing
world.
They can contribute to
sustainable development
if designed, operated,
and located properly.
Larger shopping malls are
better than smaller ones
because a larger scale allows
for diversified activities
and goods.
Malls need to be linked
with public transportation.
In the next couple
of minutes we'll
go through each of these points.
I want to highlight
why more development is
important in the sustainable
development discussion.
First, cities are noticeably
growing more vertically
than horizontally.
High skylines have
become a symbol
of our contemporary
space-limited cities.
City residents now live, work,
and play in tall buildings.
Shopping in high
rise mall is today
connected to ideals
of urban life.
Consumer behavior theories
call this image-ability,
which is connected
with the quality
in a physical object that
evokes a strong image
in the observers.
Aside from the large size of
the mall, advanced technology,
aesthetics, convenience,
organized parking,
and cleanliness,
among other factors,
improved image-ability in malls.
We therefore attract,
shoppers, promote economic
sustainability, and increasingly
becoming a good platform
for local, intra-, and
inter-regional as well
as international trade.
Malls are proven to be strategic
to central economic growth
in terms of GDP in many
countries like Dubai,
like South Africa.
In the United States,
business and education
alone account for more
than 40% of the GDP.
In 2013, retail
and wholesale trade
have created
additional 12% increase
in the country's GDP growth.
All of this growth is
mostly created in the 47,000
malls of the United States.
Again, malls are quickly
over the functions
of a public space.
And we know that public space is
important for sustainable city
development.
Malls are important
thought places.
Thought places are the
next most important place
after where we live and work.
Malls attract large
crowds and encourage
information dissemination,
social networking,
social interaction, and
economic redistribution.
This process describes
social capital formation,
which is essential for
overall community development.
This explains why
mall contributes
to social sustainability.
Now, let us narrow our focus.
One would ask, what kind of mall
design, location, and operation
promotes sustainability?
Malls are necessary
large and they generate
carbon emissions and heat.
It appears to be using mall
resources, such as electricity,
water, and chlorofluorocarbons,
through extensive use of air
conditioning,
heating, and cooling.
However, instead of
increasing carbon production,
it may be designed
to reduce it through
technical interventions.
If a mall is designed and built
using ecological principles
of green buildings,
during operations,
use environmental-friendly
and other sources,
and have efficient waste
management systems.
Sustainability is also
promoted when malls discourage
the proliferation of
informal activities
that often take
place on the roadside
and in sprawling market stalls.
These spaces are
not easily managed
because of the diverse
stakeholders involved.
Again, malls will
enhance sustainability
when its location is in a
heterogeneous environment where
there is greater land use
mix, where residents pay less
to reach it, and
where [INAUDIBLE]
such as fossil fuels are
required for transportation.
For instance, in
Putrajaya, Malaysia,
the mall studied perform less
well in times of patronage
compared to the other
one in Bukit Indah
because it is located in
a more regional setting
while the other locates in a
more heterogeneous setting.
Many residents in Putrajaya are
civil servants with two homes
and are in and out of the city.
Suburb locations of malls
like Jusco, Bukit Indah,
isolate them from
public transportation
and therefore encourage
private car use.
This leads to an increase in
energy use, which is converted
into environmental pollutants.
While the use of alternative
environmentally friendly
energy, such as electricity,
is advocated for,
using even a smaller
amount of energy
by organizing an
efficient retail center
is the whole essence
of sustainability.
Operations in the mall
contribute to sustainability.
Malls will thrive when
operations [? in ?] [? need ?]
are suitable for more
types of shoppers.
Empirical observation shows
that most shoppers are women.
They prefer malls where their
children can play safely
while they shop.
In addition to [INAUDIBLE],
cinemas, bowling,
and among other activities
which attract young adults that
have less economic
power to malls,
provisions of
children's activities
is observed to be strategic
to malls operation.
Multiple shopping
opportunities combined
with multiple types of
activities encourage patronage.
This pours economic
sustainability
and we increase the long-term
vitality of the mall.
Malls can also save space
and promote compact city
sustainable development.
The thought point is concerned
with the scale of malls.
Research shows that the bigger
the mall the better it is.
Not only does a large
mall provide opportunities
to assess diversified goods,
services, and activities,
it also reduces
shopper's cost in terms
of stress, time, and money.
A single trip will satisfy
retail, recreation,
and other needs.
Numbers of trips are
reduced, therefore reducing
the amount of energy used.
This contributes to
environmental sustainability.
Large scale and
localization of malls
may also help a city to
better plan transportation
options for shopping trips.
The largest shopping
malls will encourage
more efficient and
effective resource use.
For instance, use of security
cameras and personnel
would be effective in
a single mall compared
to many smaller
and [? scattered ?]
retail buildings.
Because of the large
scale and compactness,
waste generated in the
mall can also be large.
If the waste collection
methods are efficient,
it may encourage
industrial recycling.
All together, each
and every function
in a diversified large mall
could support one another
and allow for its
continued existence.
Large malls are those iconic.
They are like monuments
of historic significance,
making cities immeasurable
and attracting tourists
and economic prosperity.
At this point, it
is very important
to [INAUDIBLE] the importance
of public transportation system
to mall development against
a background of city
sustainability.
The late arrival of the mall
after much of the central city
had already being
developed is probably
the reason for its location in
the suburbs in many developing
countries.
This makes it
challenging to integrate
the mall into the city's
public transportation system.
Malls will be more
sustainable if effectively
integrated into the public
transportation system.
Connecting commercial areas
with intra- and or intercity
transportation of road,
rail, and where possible--
like Putrajaya-- waterways, can
improve customer convenience
and reduce pollution making
the city more sustainable.
In Malaysia, Jusco Bukit Indah
has a better overall assessment
in terms of patronage,
diversified activities,
and so on.
But it is less integrated with
public transportation compared
to Alamanda mall in Putrajaya.
Though the transportation
is better in Alamanda mall,
other important features of
a sustainable shopping mall
are still in progress.
In conclusion, for a mall to
be sustainable, especially
in Malaysia and other
developing countries,
all the factors should
be considered together.
Large malls in a well integrated
public transportation system
should offer multiple
shopping, recreation,
and social activities that
are preferred by women--
who are the largest
shoppers-- and should
be located in an area
where land use are mixed.
The beauty as well as
the general environment
should be designed using green
building and environmental
principles.
These assure us of a
sustainable shopping
mall within the framework of
sustainable city development.